hey Robby Mook nice to meet you I'm here
to say for Hillary Clinton's campaign I
just remind you to caucus on Monday
my name is Robby I'm here with Hillary
Clinton's campaign thank you so much for
your support we're gonna make history
you're gonna make history on Monday okay
we'll see you there
thanks for your support buh-bye okay
that was good we can elect the first
woman president you could be part of it
Hey how are you
I'll just leave this for her are you
planning to caucus too or no no okay
thank you we'll see you there on Monday
take care these are all people who have
made a commitment to us to turnout so at
this point we know they're supporters we
just need to make sure that they
remember to show up tell me am I going
too fast for you or something oh I like
to get a little exercise into by whoa
that is deep whoo I don't know where I'm
going though do we go this is kind of a
best practice to get people to show up
to vote that would be used in a lot of
other elections and we found it really
works so we're asking them three
questions where they're coming from so
they driving from work or driving from
home second how are they getting there
are they driving walking are they you
know using public transportation and
then who are they bringing with them oh
you're going with some friends oh that's
awesome okay great there's gonna be a
lot of turnout so it's really important
that everybody shows up so thank you for
bringing people with you if people have
to think through the process of how
they're gonna go caucus it's more likely
that they'll follow through on that and
do it so that's a really important part
of this conversation she's going yes and
are you bringing anyone else with you
from the house okay I'm gonna put a
question mark because I'm hoping you can
convince me it's gonna be very close so
we need as many people as possible we're
feeling really really good but there's
me a lot of people turning out so if
there's any way he can change his plans
and make it that's gonna make a big
difference for us so it was a not home
if they're not home we put this it's
kind of a post-it on their door yeah I
was writing a little note just you know
sorry I missed you and we'll see you on
little personal touch are you guys
volunteering today I think I met I met
him but just met one of your supporters
in there he told me he was his wife is
caucusing for Hillary but he was on the
other side just reminding you about the
caucus on Monday
yeah sure we're gonna make if we can we
will be there wonderful well it's good
as you know there's the turnouts gonna
be high it's gonna be very close so is
that kind of thing frustrating yeah no
it's hard and when somebody's like I'm
supporter but I have to do this other
things it's hard and especially because
from us this is our life you know doing
this work and in a lot of these caucus
rooms particularly in the smaller
precincts one or two people can make a
huge difference so particularly for a
couple like that I completely understand
because you don't want to be me rude and
say come on now but it does break your
heart cuz you just think this one or two
people could make such a big difference
oh my gosh yeah look at you
the specialty buttons yeah they're a lot
of you guys out here yeah that's great
how are you feeling good excellent
good that's great how are you guys
feeling we're feeling good hey my name
is Robbie
I'm here with Hillary Clinton's campaign
um was just coming by to remind you
about that caucus on Monday another one
maybe somebody already come by yeah oh
we already gave me all this yesterday Oh
wonderful okay it's in fact of anything
they're a little frustrated because
we've talked to them so many okay all
done hopefully we got one or two caucus
goers we wouldn't buy those yeah nobody
recognized you right you're kind of no
no no yeah they definitely wouldn't
recognize me